[Music]
wendy williams is out and about and
looking good we've got a lot to talk
about the talk show host who has been
under the radar for the last year due to
ongoing health issues resurfaced in new
york city at cardi b's playboy met gala
after party with media personality jason
lee wendy looked vibrant in a colorful
layered dress with matching sneakers and
a diamond encrusted w pendant and
necklace to complete the look and jason
looked dapper by her side in a tuxedo yo
came to new york for the meg gala but i
wasn't going to come outside without the
sexiest date
in new york city to commemorate their
timeout jason shared this video of wendy
all smiles and bunny ears to instagram
[Music]
during her night out the talk show host
who seemed to be in great spirits also
doubled down on her return to tv by
telling tmz that she plans to be back as
host on the wendy williams show in the
fall
this comes after wendy's rare outing at
a dinner last month in new york city
where at the time a source told et that
she was discussing getting back to work
by way of making a big comeback on tv
but also last month it was announced the
wendy williams show is coming to an end
and shari shepherd who's been one of
wendy's many guest hosts since last fall
is set to have her own talk show titled
sheri on top of her tv comeback another
priority for wendy is accessing her
frozen accounts from wells fargo and
getting her money back please let me
have access to my money this is not
right and again this is not fair as fans
may recall wendy is in an ongoing battle
with wells fargo and her former
financial advisor who she claims is
keeping her from her millions and in
true wendy fashion she wanted to let her
supporters know what's really going on
laurie schiller and wells fargo
have
this
guardianship petition
about
keeping me away from my money
this is not right
and you know this is not fair wells
fargo previously alleged the 57 year old
star is an incapacitated person who
needs a guardianship and can't access
her money but a resolution might be on
the horizon a source tells e.t her focus
at this time is regaining access to her
finances which she believes will happen
really soon as for now wendy is slowly
but surely getting back into the new
york city life
[Music]
you